hello everyone my name is subhabrito
mukherjee and i'm a senior researcher at
microsoft research
today i am going to talk about resource
efficient learning for large pregnant
models
there is a joint work with several
researchers interns and our internal
collaborators
our core mission is to bring intelligent
ai experiences to every person and
organization in this world which means
we need to build ai models for thousands
of different tasks domains and languages
however it is quite difficult to custom
build models for every domain and
organization or language that we want to
support even if we can afford the
annotation cost in many cases we cannot
even see or annotate the data due to
privacy in compliance reasons
in this regard we have been working a
lot on data efficient learning on how to
scale ai to hundreds of different tasks
and thousands of domains but with only
few limited examples or demonstrations
so first i'm going to talk a bit about
self training
and for most of the practical tasks you
have some label data and large amounts
of task specific unlabeled data self
training as a semi supervised learning
has been quite effective in these
settings where you train the teacher
model on some amount of label data you
apply the teacher model
to the task specific unlabeled data to
collect the logits which we call the
augmented data this augmented data can
be used to train a student model the
teacher and student model share
parameters and the training is repeated
until convergence however a typical
challenge with this setup is error
propagation from the noisy pseudo levels
this equation shows the connection
between self training and entropy
regularization there are two loss terms
here the first one is the cross entropy
loss over limited level data and the
second one is zero level loss over
unlabeled data here we can do
intelligent sample selection to prevent
drift from the noisy pseudo levels
in recent times we have been exploring a
lot of techniques to improve the
regularization and sample selection for
few short self training
we have been exploring several
techniques like stochastic
regularization to leverage uncertainty
estimates of the underlying neural
network
or
leveraging the self-generated model
explanations
in the form of rationalism to make it
learn better
or even weak supervision in the form of
domain specific signals like regular
expression
uh and so on so to give you a flavor of
one such technique uh let us consider
this work where we use dropout
distribution for stochastic
regularization so we sample several
masked model weights given a pre-trained
language model using dropout
now given an
unlabeled sample you can pass this
through each of these different masked
models
collect the predictions aggregate them
compute the mean and variance which
gives you an estimate of the uncertainty
estimate of the neural network for the
underlying sample
we can incorporate these estimates into
the self-training framework to make it
learn better
furthermore you can use this uncertainty
estimates to do sample selection
and leverage the teacher confidence so
that the student can learn from
confident teacher pseudo levels given by
the samples with low variance
we applied this technique of uncertainty
about self training to several text
classification benchmark datasets where
our method which is the one in yellow is
trained with only 30 labels for each
class for each task compared to birth
which is trained on thousands of levels
and we note that we can perform within
three percentage of the fully supervised
model
the previous technique applied to
sentence classification tasks is a bit
difficult to adapt to structured
classification tasks
like named entity recognition and slot
tagging in this work we developed meta
st to bridge this gap
in meta ist we leverage meta learning to
do re-weighting for token level pseudo
levels by injecting perturbations at the
tokens and then doing consistency
learning
we observe that our method meta sd can
outperform several state-of-the-art
methods with at least 10 percentage
improvement in the 10-shot setting means
that we can use
only 10 labeled examples for each slot
type
in all of the previous techniques we use
classic fine tip bird style fine tuning
in recent times prompt tuning has proven
to be much more effective in from tuning
we used the pre-trained language
modeling head to do closest style
sentence completion task which bridges
the gap between pre-training and
fine-tuning
we incorporate this prompt tuning
method into our previous meta metastatic
framework which we now call prompt st
and we have several observations we
observe that a better teacher
since prompt tuning is better than find
classical fine tuning in the low
resource scenario can lead to a better
student where we observe prompt to be
greater than meta st we also observe
that self training with unlabeled data
can improve prompt tuning in the low
resource scenarios
while doing the previous works we noted
that there is a lack of benchmark to
evaluate true few short learning
especially there are several challenging
questions on whether we should use a
validation set how many shorts or levels
should be used to compare the model
performance which tasks or metrics that
we should use
in order to address all of these
different questions we developed the
clues benchmark bluestand stands for
constraint language understanding
evaluation standard in which we release
several tasks and data sets
diverse scenarios like in er reasoning
and classification
uh with human level performance
evaluation
uh here we observed that there is really
a huge gap between human and machine
performance for fu shot nlu where humans
really do well given only few
demonstrative examples now let me shift
gear and talk a bit about
scalability
this pre-trade language models are huge
in size and it is difficult to use them
in practice
so let me first talk a bit about
adapters so the core idea here is to use
small tunable components or bottleneck
layers in different layers of the neural
network model now instead of tuning the
entire language model head to end to end
we will only tune this small adapter
components this makes it really
efficient
to deploy it for multiple tasks and
scenarios but i need to keep only one
copy of the original language model and
several task specific small adapter
parameters we use this idea with prompt
st and we observe that we can keep the
same performance as before but now with
prompt st adapter we are using only four
percent tunable parameters compared to
that before finally
adapters do not really resolve the
inference latency challenge
as the model architecture is the same as
before in this work we have been
exploring knowledge distillation to self
train a student model given the hidden
state representations and attention
state transfer from the big teacher
model using these techniques we
distilled several universal checkpoints
with several magnitudes of faster
inference compared to the big teacher
model but with matching performance
we released these checkpoints in the
links below
thanks a lot for your attention you can
refer
to the following links for more
information